hey everyone and welcome back I needed
an excuse to put on some underwear and a
t-shirt so I figured I would go get
myself on camera and uh if you're
noticing right now that my skin seems a
bit
I don't know perhaps shiny maybe moist
it's not what you think it is I've begun
a skincare routine to hopefully fix my
gross pepperoni face so uh now that I've
gone through this little opening ramp
let's go ahead get started we'll talk
about detecting concurrent rights how we
can do that how this is better than last
right wins and uh yeah let's just go
ahead and get into it so I can get
myself to sleep
so if we recall where we left off from
last time basically I introduced the
concept of multi-leader replication so
it means now that instead of just having
to write to one place we can actually
write to a bunch of different places
which is really nice for increasing
right throughput at the same time we run
into the potential of Riot conflicts so
how can we actually address those
conflicts well one way is by giving
every single right a timestamp but time
stamps aren't very reliable so let's
look at a potentially better way of
doing so so to introduce today's video
we're going to start with the concept of
trying to build a distributed counter
using a multi-leader replication setup
so like I mentioned we've got our
distributed counter we've got two liters
right over here and over here and the
gist is that you know we've got one guy
writing to our left leader doing
increments we've got another guy writing
to our Right leader also doing
increments so let's imagine we've got
our version one over here so in version
one the left guy has a count of three
the right guy has a count of five and
let's say now that uh it gets to the
point where they're sending their rights
to one another so they can actually you
know go ahead and confirm uh the values
that they have so the left guy is going
to send three to the right the right guy
is going to send five to the left well
how are they actually going to rectify
these how do we merge this right
conflict because they both disagree on
the value well I guess one way that
would be pretty simple would just be hey
you know five is a higher number than
three probably there's just been two
more rights that we didn't account for
on the left side just yet and now we
should set the left to five you know so
we would do something like this
and uh you know five basically just
stays as five on the right because you
know five is bigger than three so in
theory
that could work however in practice it
obviously doesn't why not because the
guy on the left who was writing those
three times to the left is different
than the guy on the right who is writing
five times so the ideal result that we
actually want to be getting is eight
that's the correct answer so this should
introduce ideally the concept of
concurrent rights basically we know that
we have two people on the left and the
right writing at the same time they
don't know about each other's rights
right they haven't seen those rights
before they're doing their own and as a
result that's what makes them concurrent
you may have heard the term concurrent
before meaning two things happening at
the same time but truthfully uh you know
they can happen at slightly different
times but as long as they didn't know
about each other that is what makes them
concurrent so let's talk about version
two which I'm sure you were already
starting to think about because example
one was clearly pretty stupid
which is this concept of a version
Vector so let's go ahead and talk about
that as I zoom in this window
pardon me okay we're properly zoomed so
this time instead of just storing a
counter on each database we're actually
going to store the number of increments
that we've seen from each leader node so
in the starting State remember that we
had a guy on the left writing three
times hence the version Vector three
comma zero in the first index of this
Vector we know that we've seen three
increments the left side and zero
increments to the right side
similarly on the right side we've had
five increments so now we've seen zero
increments from the left side and five
increments from the right side do recall
that eventually these databases are
going to send their rights to one
another so when that happens they can
both send the actual counter value but
they can also send the version Vector so
instead of literally just going and
setting a naive counter now we have this
version vector and what we can do is
merge them so as you can see on both
sides it's going to result in a version
Vector of 3 and 5 and a counter of eight
why because the left side has been
incremented three times the right side
has been incremented five times and so
now we can just go ahead and combine
those values and the total counter is
going to be the sum of the entries in
that version Vector you know 8 is
obviously equal to three plus five
so now what if uh something were to
happen where basically the left side
gets incremented again see over here
we've got one increment and now the left
side turns into nine because we're
incrementing our counter by one and the
left side has been updated four times
the right side at least according to the
left has still only been updated five
times So eventually what's going to
happen is that version Vector of four
five with a counter of nine is going to
be passed to the right side and what
we'll say is okay on the right we now
see that a counter of nine is coming in
are we just going to add 9 to our count
of eight no we're not going to because
that would give us 17 and that would be
wrong the truth is that this 9 and 8
have a significant amount of overlap how
much overlap do they have well the three
and the five themselves overlap so the
only difference is actually this four
right here so we're only just adding one
to our version Vector saying okay now
we've seen one more increment from the
left leader and now our counter is nine
okay so hopefully you guys are starting
to get the concept of this but the point
is version vectors basically just keep
track of how many increments they've
seen from each leader database
okay so let's do a little bit of thought
exercise now how can we actually see
which rights are concurrent by using
version vectors so let's imagine we've
got these three liters right here right
oh oh and they're in an all to all
replication setup which keep in mind
that means that any right can be sent to
any node and it puts no guarantees on
The Ordering of when certain rights are
getting two nodes within that
replication
so notice now that we've got two one two
over here on the top what does that mean
it means that it's basically go ahead
and scene two rights from our left
leader it's seeing one right from the
bottom guy and it's seen two rights from
itself
okay now what if you were basically
getting past 111 from the bottom node
right so it goes one one all the way up
here we've got some right with some
value in the version Vector Associated
is one comma one comma one well
basically what this guy would say is I'm
going to disregard
we're not making any changes to this
leader because we've already accounted
for all of those rights why is that
because 2 comma 1 comma 2 is strictly
greater than or equal to one comma one
comma one which means that we've already
accounted for two rights in the first
leader one right and the second leader
and two rights in the third leader so
any right that comes to us by saying
we've only accounted for one right and
the first leader one right and the
second and one right and the third we've
already accounted for all of those in
our leader and so we don't have to make
any changes so we know that a version
Vector where all of the entries are
strictly greater than or equal to all of
the entries of another version Vector we
can say that the first right has come
after
the second right they are not concurrent
on the other hand if the opposite
applies we can say with certainty that
those two rights are concurrent for
example look at B's over here
five is greater than four but two is
less than three and so what that means
is that one of the servers
has seen one more right than the other
that went to leader number one but that
Sam server has seen one less right from
leader two which means that these two
rights could not have possibly known
about each other
if you need to take a second pause think
about this concept but the gist is that
if we have two basically interleav
inversion vectors we know that those two
rights could not have possibly known
about each other they must have been
concurrent and so what can we actually
do when we realize that rights are
concurrent
well let's think about it option one is
to store siblings so let's say I've got
one guy over here who writes Jordan is
scary and then we've got a second guy on
the left who writes Jordan as cute so
according to our version vectors we know
that the version Vector for Jordan
equals Q is one comma zero why because
there's been one right on the left side
and zero writes on the right side
at least accounted for in this leader
and then similarly the guy who writes
Jordan equal scary has an Associated
version Vector of zero comma one why
because this database node hasn't seen
any rights from leader one but it now
has one right for itself
and so we look at these two things and
we'll say okay well one comma zero and
zero comma one how do they compare
well in this case one is greater than
zero but zero is less than one so they
must be concurrent
and if they are concurrent that means
that this is a right conflict and so if
it's a right conflict what can we do
well we can actually store both rights
in our database that's known as storing
the siblings so an example of a database
right here now would be the key is
Jordan but the value is either cute and
or scary I know on both things and so
one way of actually kind of resolving
this conflict is the next time that
anyone makes a read from our databases
once they kind of combine and have both
values
is you can actually offer the user a
choice say hey wait a second we see in
the database that you know there are two
different values so do you choose cute
or scary and then once that value is
chosen we can now delete one of them and
now we've resolved our merge conflict so
that's one way of doing things to
actually use the application layer and
the user in order to manually resolve
merge conflicts another one is actually
to have the database do it automatically
so this is kind of the premise behind
something known as crdts or
conflict-free replicated data types so
the premise here is that by effectively
detecting concurrent rights we can
figure out a smart way to merge them and
so there are a few different types of
data structures that we can build where
we can actually basically make them
write conflict resistant one example
would be a counter which is effectively
the same thing as a version Vector right
we saw the counter earlier in this video
you can build a counter that is
conflict-free because all you have to do
is go ahead and merge those version
vectors and now we have a counter
similarly you can do something like that
with a set and possibly even more
complicated data types I'm going to
leave this concept until next video but
so far at least I hope all of this has
made sense we've got one more tough one
with the crdts and then we're going to
go into leaderless replication